[Music]
some are rusty is argued that so that
you can't be you know it's idiotic to
say you're about politics because
politics is all around you and above you
and beneath you it I was resistant to
that idea but it's clearly true isn't it
that that it's very hard to imagine a
piece of writing or a long ish speech
that doesn't have a political bearing on
a saw so I think neutrality is a is a
chimera it's it's not there it's it's a
mythical creature and even-handedness is
its own trap as well I mean if if the
the press had not been so quote-unquote
even-handed we would have President
Clinton and not president Trump some
some things are so clearly wrong you
know so unsure Khalil advised that that
I think you know being even-handed about
it is ridiculous what do you do to with
Alex Jones and and those people who
harass the the bereaved parents of Sandy
Hook or parkland Florida and say and and
threaten them with death and say they're
you know
worthless crisis actors and I'm not
gonna sit down and say well let's go
through your points one after the other
and we hear a great deal about being
respectful to people who's I you know
white supremacist I'm not gonna be
respectful I haven't got it in me to be
respectable be respectful of that
something's a malum per se evil in
themselves and the crisis active
business is one of them